Good morning John; it's Friday, November 7th.
Almost three years ago, you and I decided
to do something that was really hard, but
that we really wanted to do.
Eventually, with a lot of help, Crash Course
became a thing.
And a lot of teachers and a lot of students
use it.
We've kept it free; it's available for anyone
with an internet connection, and it is – and
I say this with a deep love for the Pemberley
Digital stuff and SciShow and VidCon and the
Wimbly Womblys – the best thing that we
do.
It is a thing that I am very proud of, and
so, with a tear in my eye, here's a look back
at the last three years of Crash Course.
J: Hi, I'm John Green.
This is Crash Course World History, and today
we're gonna talk about civilization.
H: I'm Hank Green and I wanna teach you chemistry.
But, please, do not run away screaming.
H: People may not be the easiest organisms
to understand, but – you're a person, right?
J: Oh god, Stan, it's Me From College.
Me From the Past has become Me From College.
This is a disaster!
H: Nothing escapes the long arm of ecology.
H: Like any good 50 Cent song, biology is
just about sex and not dying.
J: The test will last your entire life, and
it will be comprised of the millions of decisions
that, when taken together, make your life
yours.
And everything – everything!
– will be on it.
[Crash Course theme music]
The only reason Crash Course works is because
people like it.
Most of the people who watch Crash Course
do it because they want to, not because they
have to.
For the first two years of Crash Course, it
was funded by a Google grant, basically.
Then that Google money ran out, and we had
to figure out how to keep making the show.
So basically, we just asked.
We asked people who liked Crash Course if
they'd like to give a little bit of money
so that it could keep existing for them, and
also for all of the other people in the world.
We didn't wanna start charging for it; we
didn't wanna put it on an exclusive platform
where only people using that platform could
get it.
We got a lot of offers to do those sorts of
things and to make fair amounts of money doing
it.
We didn't want to lock the content down, but
it looked like we might have had to – BUT:
People decided to just give us money through
Subbable.
Crash Course relies hugely on that support
and I could never be more grateful for it.
It means we get to keep making better and
more content.
We've also done some partnerships; the Big
History series that we're in the middle of
right now is in partnership with the Bill
Gates Think Tank BGC3.
And now we're working on a significantly larger
relationship with PBS Digital Studios.
They're gonna allow us to basically double
the amount of content that we're doing on
Crash Course.
Of course, PBS, just like Crash Course, is
largely funded by people who watch and love
PBS stuff.
So it's sort of a natural fit.
And we've worked with these people before;
we've liked them; we worked with them on Frankenstein
MD, and the Art Assignment.
So in 2015, we're hopefully doing four Crash
Courses:
Craig Benzine, aka WheezyWaiter, will be doing
a government class.
Phil Plait, who is probably the most successful
astronomy blogger in the world, will be doing
Crash Course Astronomy.
I will be doing Crash Course Physiology –
And we're still working on it, but hopefully
we will also be doing Crash Course Economics.
If you haven't checked out Crash Course yet,
there's a ton of really interesting content:
history, biology, and chemistry, ecology,
and literature, and soon, government and astronomy
and physiology and eCOnomics – eCOnomics?
Did I really just say eCOnomics?
EcoNOMics.
Is what I meant to say.
PBS Digital Studios does a ton of really interesting
stuff as well, there's a link to their channel
in the description.
And finally, unrelated to any of this, I have
an announcement to make: John and I, starting
Monday, will be doing The Twelve Days of Pizzamas.
During those twelve days, John and I will
make a video every day except for the weekends.
Just like Brotherhood 2.0, there's gonna be
a lot of vlogbrothers content coming at you,
so be ready.
I'm doing Monday, Wednesday, Friday next week
and then Tuesday, Thursday the week after
that.
So you're gonna see a lot of Paper Towns set,
and the videos are gonna decrease in quality
cause we're gonna have to make so many of
them, and we're probably gonna go a little
bit insane, and it's gonna be great.
I'm actually really looking forward to it.
I feel like it's getting back to my roots,
you know?
I want a little a bit more back and forth,
I wanna feel more connected to it all, and
so this is gonna be a good two weeks.
Pizzamas begins on Monday.
So I'm gonna make two videos in a row, so:
John, I will see you on Tuesday, and you will
see me on Monday.